hi guys my name is Tamra chambers and
this is cameras ever seen and today I am
doing Groundhog Day no that's not I'll
do that's right
so dumb I'm doing John wicks today I
have been getting from a bunch of people
that I should do John wick and I looked
it up this is a 2014 movie like of
course items you guys but we're going to
try a new series called Tamra Jessa I
serious knowing what people are talking
about for me Tamra's never seen episodes
but then also being like up-to-date on
current movies too if it's a whole new
world guys
groundhog and grabs to carl winslow the
diehard saloon I'm ring Leia buns I
can't flip on the raw holding on by it's
the red saris I've been doing John wick
today which I feel indifferent about
all-time I've never seen holy crap that
was so much better than I thought it was
going to be here we go John wick so
excited he wasn't doing it for me acting
wise right at the top like oh my god
Keanu Reeves come on buddy you got this
buddy just cars amazing though 69
Mustang I love old cars I always say if
I had a ton of money what I would spend
my money on it old cars they said a
really old car I think I've shown that
in this series of little Marcus Williams
film comes to John's wife's funeral and
you see that their friend is sort of
talking about the bad acting so willing
to pose like how you holding up and
Keanu Reeves John is like I keep asking
myself why her just slow a dead Dan I'm
just like alright well here's this is
how it's gonna go
here's the movie excellent then I wrote
down I'm a crusty bitch oh god do i stir
that in there yeah
to do it so then I wrote down I'm a
crusty bitch for making fun of his
acting because that job seemed here's
forever so his wife like right before
she died apparently sends him this puppy
he started crying dashing is amazing and
then forget everything I just said you
see this topic if it's so cute oh my god
and just very excited to them to fight
crime together for I was he's at a gas
station in his awesome car was awesome
dog and he runs into some Russian people
they like his car so one of them asks
how much he wants for it and he's like
it's not for sale and the guy starts
speaking Russian to him he's like
Russian Russian Russian Russian Russian
Russian and Jon's like I can speak
Russian - Russian Russian Russian and
you're like oh shoot this guy's legit
Grovetown oh my god he gives her cereal
in reference to Daisy the dog next thing
I wrote is what the that is in reference
to the Russian guys breaking into his
house beating the shit out of him and
then killing Daisy oh my god I was so
upset this character Daisy she just
captured every being every point of
being in my body I just love her so much
I'm so upset
no no did what the ball with the ball
it's a nice car but with the ball and
then he wakes up from being really hurt
sees the dead dog that his dead wife
gifted to him as a way to mourn with
someone else and then the next thing is
him burying the dog no feel like I need
to say the spoilers in this because this
is just from 2014 so it's kind of new
maybe you haven't back in the future I'm
like okay I'm going to give all this
pretty much because they're not spoilers
anyway so this is the story of a man
getting back his mother effin car kind
of like taking bullet cars so the little
douche goes I don't know his name guys
it didn't didn't learn it now but he
goes to his powerful daddy and but at
this time the dad knows now
and the dad's like ah so John wick dude
that you do that you've done John wick
that guy yeah he is called the boogie
man and he's going to come for you
there's nothing you can do so get out of
my sight I'm cursing so much in this
episode
vo powerful daddy video calls John wit
cuz they used to work together so he
calls John he's like hey what's a sixth
of like humans
John just hangs up on him and I had this
one I was like well your son is oh your
son is dead she's definitely gonna die
if he doesn't die I'm gonna be upset
there's a weird thing that I'm like
rooting for this man to kill this little
baby child boy who's an idiot like I
wanted to die and they said John's
character up so well that you're like
yeah yeah kill whoever you I don't even
care who you kill just whoever you want
then like you he'll like you so then
Viggo sends this whole group of 12 men
to go take out jobs if he doesn't take
out his son and it is an incredible
fight scene lots of gun work but a lot
of like hand-to-hand fighting which is
super exciting to watch and the most
impressive part about this acuteness
soufiane tired of fighting and he
doesn't leave his house they come to his
house so he just gets dressed up in a
suit just to take out these guys that's
the most dapper thing you could ever do
ever so just and the doorbell rings so
john opens the door and it's his cop
named Jimmy and Jimmy's like hey John
Shawn's like hey dude
so uh the noise complaint just like yeah
let me see use all the bodies he's like
uh you work in jobs like just working
some things out and he's like alright
I'll leave you to it night John and so
like people so respect this character
it's not out of fear it feels like it
feels like just as admiration people
just really like this guy
other cool aspect if he calls this
number and he's like I want to make a
dessert business dinner reservation for
12 this guy comes over
and take care of the 12 body it's such a
cool way to do it also he paid for
everything with gold coins which is
another mysterious and great aspect of
this character so Vigo offers Marcus two
million dollars to kill him I wanted to
ask you personally because I know your
friends but we have something going on
and I would like you to be the one to
pick him out he's like yeah sure man got
you and made me so sad because he showed
it to his wife humoring and and their
friends and I don't want anyone to kill
John wicks and I know that if anyone's
going to do is we William to fall like
that about
so John checks into this hotel that you
quickly find is this hub for people who
do what he does John finds out where the
Sun punk guy is and he goes to kill him
and it turns out to be this weird
safehouse is just also a party there's
like strobe light happening and house
music is blaring which makes the
filmography as what I was about to say
the iographer that's the word so they
thought it'd be really cool in this
scene because it's like John kills like
it seems like 30 guards who are watching
this little punk kid and and the kid
gets away which is a bummer John goes
back to the hotel where he's staying at
and they have a doctor on retainer
because it's a full of a bunch of people
like John wick John got really hurt in
this fight and the doctors like you
shouldn't move for a long time but I
imagine your work isn't done yet so just
take these pills if you have to formally
action films the doctors like don't do
anything in the guy that I'm going to
anyway
bah boom boom then you see Marcus Willem
Dafoe up with his sniper rifle that you
figured it because of John but he
doesn't that's a killer like so he just
like watching his back and it's really
cool all your faces are stored and
William Dafoe I know all of you were
worried John goes to this place that
Viggo is fronting as a church but it's
actually storing all of his money all of
his like blackmail file he goes and she
shoots everyone there except for this
woman who I actually think is at church
a dangerous game going to church I know
where I was good he gets inside this
vault and he sets everything of ablaze
and it's victorious and wonderful so he
who captures him and then willing him to
stroll back at it again with the tonight
for rifle takedown the guys who are
taking up John
he goes like no Kelly I'll tell you
where my son is just let me live which
is just like wait wait wait what Jim Jim
son's life up so that he doesn't die
which engines are sensible I guess maybe
I would do the thing painting iron
trying to be like high and mighty here
let me say it was like a moment where
you're like oh oh
John knows where the Sun is now go to
him
kills it Marcus is like how many times
you have to save you man and it's a good
friend moment John is like wow and
retired now Marcus is like ah excuse me
there's a second movie coming out no
you're not
nito captures Marcus John is like well
the movies not over yet folks don't
think it so on a very climactic
action-packed frenzy of a scene he
killed Viggo they like drop their guns
they they spy it's awesome then in
literally the best scene of the entire
movie maybe seen in the entire world
he breaks into a pound and takes a
pitbull puppy I want to go so bad with
all of my heart don't tell likes but
mostly we had everything and has good
acting had good story it had good action
and it had dogs everything the quads
best of movies I thought it was just a
generic action film that people were
telling me I should see because the
second one is coming out soon and I'd
love it so so much
but like I said at the beginning this
goes up on Saturday Tamara's never seen
is on Saturday and tomorrow Sunday I'm
putting up a Tamara Jessa of John wick -
I don't think the title names but the
second one thank you so much for
watching you guys I am so glad that I
watched film thank you so much for
telling me that I should watch this I'll
see you tomorrow
with John wick -
Groundhog Day - and I'll see you guys
next week
[Music]